à des fins
qu'est ce qu'on mange mais no more gaza
c'est ce jeudi de quoi lombez tu
reconnais pourquoi est ce si ce lourd
galles ce 6 cd saucisses des tomates et
des oignons
maintenant les connais pas ça a l'air
bon patès comment la fin je crois que le
surveillant arrive à enfin je chante un
peu de soleil ou à la rue enfin cinq là
l'eau des puits charme y arrive
ah c'est ça ou des saucisses
non merci
mais préfère qu zemlin f salez peu à une
nouvelle idée
[Musique]
flaminio
l'aïe avait peint une turbine safran qui
met pas safran de rodage
[Musique]
j'en ai juste un petit peu mais oui oui
atterré mange tout
c'est très vite et le style du primaire
avec un seul bobby moore qu'ils ont ce
traquenard est peut-être celle
[Musique]
vous avez également
il
oh
[Musique]